[Music]
cory is in little rock hi corey welcome
to the ramsay show what's up
hi gay how are you better than i deserve
how can we help
my name is corey
um i'm 32
and
i
my boss just passed away a couple weeks
ago
and so he left me
some money
and so i'm just trying to really figure
out what i'm supposed to do like my dad
has told me what i need to do but it's
just it's a lot going on and i'm just
trying to because i don't have a job now
since my boss passed away but
boss left you money in his will
yes
wow that's an unusual arrangement
i was his personal assistant for eight
years
okay
yeah so he he did um
he was an oil contractor
and so i did all his
scheduling everything i was
as he used to call me his go-to go-to
gal
all the time so i mean i just kept up
with all his books and everything that
he needed done
and so after i knew he didn't have he
didn't have family then
he did he did
okay so his wife is the one that
actually
called me and let me know that i was
left something oh okay so he didn't
leave everything to you no no no no no
no i'm just trying it's just an unusual
story it's a wonderful story but i'm
trying to understand so the uh how much
did he leave you
1.25
million dollars
yes
wow
oh my god
i i
couldn't vote i couldn't believe
what i mean what was the old guy worth a
billion or something
uh he he he he has a lot i mean several
properties i've
helped him
manage his properties
he would take me on trips with him and
his family my kids he took care of my
kids i mean wow he was an amazing person
wow so are you married
no okay how old are your kiddos
i have a 15 year old a four-year-old a
three-year-old and 11 month old what was
your income before before you lost your
job
i was making 65 okay 65 000 a year
1.25 million wow and i was pretty much
living paycheck to paycheck doing that i
mean i shouldn't have but
i mean my kids are
i'm doing it on my own so yeah so do you
have any debt currently any consumer
yes i have um student loans and i have
about forty thousand dollars in student
loans
um we're renting an apartment so
just month by month that's twelve
hundred dollars for our rent
and then my car my mom gave me
um her car so i have a 2006 honda
odyssey
museum right
well you're very wise you sound a little
bit overwhelmed by this a little bit
scared
my dad suggested
that i because my boss was very flexible
with my
went because he knew i had kids and
everything so it was a lot of i could
work from home doing calls calls and
everything like that i could do a lot of
stuff from home
but now
i don't think if i get another job i
will have that and it's kind of a
viewpoint my dad was looking at so he
was thinking like maybe if i take a
break until my youngest who's 11 month
old starts kindergarten
because right now it would be like
daycare for all of them well minus my 15
year old it would be daycare for all of
them and
he doesn't think that it would be wise
for me to go back to work just yet and
just
use the money
i don't i don't know okay all right well
what what i would suggest you do is that
you build a
um
let me kind of pan back let's just zoom
back for a second from worrying about
uh
what we're doing tomorrow
overall
someone just handed you 1.25 million
dollars to manage
that's your new job
and you don't know how to do it
okay is that right
yes that's why you call me
yeah and that doesn't make you bad it
doesn't make you bad it's just that
you've never managed 1.2 million dollars
before right
no
definitely not so what you do when you
have
a responsibility that large
which is what this is it's not a woohoo
i hit the lottery moment and i don't
hear that in your voice by the way
i hear a little bit of fear a little bit
of grief still from your friend passing
away a little bit of shock and awe which
i have in my voice that you got this
much money from your employer that's
pretty cool
and uh
so
here's what i suggest that people do
you need to a
number one
move
slowly
okay if you feel urgency or someone
pushing you
stop
okay
because where may people make mistakes
when they don't know what they're doing
is they go too fast let's pretend you're
driving a car for the very first time
i took my kid out in the church parking
lot with the jeep and the straight shift
to teach them how to do the strike drive
and to do the straight shift the first
rule is don't even change gears let's
just figure out and move
slowly get in trouble
stop
right and that's what you're going to do
here because it's something you've never
done before
okay
second rule is the bible says in the
multitude of counsel there is safety
so i want you to build your own advisory
group your own board of directors
not to tell you what to do
but to advise you and teach you and then
you decide what to do
okay you got a pencil
yes you ready to write
okay
first thing you need is you need an
investment advisor
click smart vester at
dot ramseysolutions.com you can find one
that we suggest
the second thing you need is a tax
advisor click tax elp ramsey solutions
dot com and find one that you like
the third thing that you need
is sometime in the next year i suspect
you're probably going to buy a home and
pay cash for it an inexpensive home
under two hundred thousand dollars
okay and you're going to need a good
real estate agent that's your third
person on your board on your advisory
board again we've got elps that can sit
down with you and help you with that
you need to make sure you have the right
kinds of insurance in place
so you need an insurance health
insurance anymore there you go you need
insurance in place and you again we've
got elps to help you with insurance
we're not in any of these businesses but
we've got people set up to where you can
form your advisory board and their goal
is not to tell you what to do and your
goal is not to hire a babysitter
you're a grown woman so your goal is to
gather information from advisors and by
which you go slow enough that you learn
and then you make the decisions
okay
and i think you can buy a home for cash
and invest some of this and not have to
go back to work
okay
i can do like my dad said yep
but it's not it's not by using the money
it's by investing the money and using
the money that the investment creates
okay we're not going to use any of the
money
we're going to put it in an investment
and it throws off an income for you to
live on
okay with your investment advisor and
you're going to not need a lot of income
because your house is going to be paid
for and your car is going to be paid for
you're not going to have any debt and
you're going to be on a budget
okay because like i said i was paycheck
to paycheck you're not going to live
paycheck to paycheck anymore you're just
going to tell every dollar what it's
going to do that's coming in you're
gonna have more dollars than you used to
have
okay and i want you to go through ramsey
plus go through financial peace
university and learn how to handle money
i'm gonna pay for that we're gonna give
it to you for a year
because you've got to get up on top of
this thing or you're going to live with
this horrible taste on the back of your
tongue called regret
move slowly and learn and put advisors
in your corner
hold on kelly will pick up and we'll
help